the david pakman show subreddit is truly
one of the best places on the internet I
would argue for sensible sober and
respectful political discussions more
than 15,000 of our viewers and listeners
are now subscribed at david pakman.com
slash read it and I want to look at a
couple of posts that I noticed that are
interesting one is from a user called
bad smash 4 who says do David's videos
get titled in such a way as to
specifically attract right-wingers I
really dislike the way David's videos
are titled I always have they're always
very click Beatty they don't represent
what David has to offer as an analyst
here's the thing and he says do a my
deliberately tithing vid titling videos
this way to attract right-wingers and if
so that that would actually be a
respectful thing to do listen we do what
what I I think that the entire youtube
titling a status quo is basically a game
and we approach it satirically which is
we will make satirical titles that are
not necessarily inaccurate but they are
satirically sensational so you know when
I when I'm interviewed on some other
show we will upload it as you know david
destroyed by facts and logic it's satire
because there's a contingent of the
right that loves to talk about how all
these right-wingers like ben shapiro are
destroying lefties with facts and logic
like that it's not serious it's not
specifically to attract a particular
audience it's just playing around with
internet memes and that's it I wouldn't
read too much more into it and remember
that in the end the title is just a
title the bulk of what we're doing is
really the content and as long as we're
not being you know truly deceptive you
know these are basically meme titles and
jokes and satire or whatever and I get
not everybody might get it but I feel
pretty good about the titles that we're
using and you know we're doing what we
can with YouTube metadata to get the
biggest possible audience cuz that's the
important thing another user LBJ's pns
interesting says complains Monday's show
had
euro mention of Bernie's rally David
complains about losing viewership when
he talks about the polls however I think
his pro Warren bias is coming out
whenever Warren does anything in the
polls he's all over it like white on
rice
Bernie holds the largest rally of this
political season and crickets and I
actually pointed out we don't really
cover rallies like we just we just don't
cover rallies if something noteworthy
happens at a rally like for example the
attempted identity politics game that a
reporter tried playing with AOC and
Bernie at that rally we covered that but
this is one of those places where if all
you have is a hammer everything looks
like a nail
if all you want to see is some kind of
anti Bernie Pro Warren bias on the
program you will find both the coverage
of things and the lack of coverage of
things to feed that narrative when the
truth is we just don't cover that a
rally took place what we cover is
whether interesting things are said at a
rally that warrant analysis if unusual
things take place and therefore we
covered yesterday in the context of
mentioning this was I believe the
biggest rally of the political season we
covered the content of an interview that
took place that's it don't read more
into things than what is actually
warranted by the facts join the
discussion at the David Pakman show
subreddit david pakman.com slash re d di
t